لقد سجلت الرقم القياسي لأدنى عدد من النسيان البالغ
8.5 بوصات في عام 2010 وأنا فخورة جدًا بأن
اسمي شيرمان دي كامبل وأنا
راقصة على مستوى عالمي
[موسيقى]
أنا أصلاً من ترينيداد وتوباغو
التي نشأت أيضًا فيها رقصة النسيان
لقد كانت رقصة عند الاستيقاظ
ترمز إلى الدخول من حياة إلى
أخرى الآن اليوم حرفياً في
كل مكان دخلت فيه إلى فن النسيان
في سن الرابعة عشرة ، كانت جدتي
راقصة في طي النسيان ، كانت والدتي تلوح في الأفق
هناك ، ومن الصحيح أنني
تذكر الإجابة التي كان عليّ أن أحملها على
هذا الإرث ليس فقط لعائلتي ولكن
أيضًا لثقافتي أيضًا جسديًا
أنا مرن جدًا ، فأنا أقوم بتمارين الإطالة اليومية
لا أستطيع حقًا أن أشعر بالإطالات الطبيعية
لذلك يجب أن أحب إنشاء
أشعر حقًا بتمدد ساقي ، أشعر
بالجنون قليلاً في بعض الأحيان من أجل
جعلها أقل من 8.5 بوصات ، ولا بد
لي من حبس أنفاسي من أجل تلويث جسدي
لجعله أسفل الشريط في نفس الوقت الذي
يجب أن أفكر فيه بذراعي  لا بد لي من
التفكير في بلدي  تموضع أتحرك جنبًا
إلى جنب فقط لإظهار
أنني معلق جدًا ، وأبدأ في التحرك
فعليًا تحت العارضة وهذا إلى
حد كبير عندما أكون قادرًا على ترك الهواء
يخرج وعندما أستيقظ يكون الأمر
صعبًا للغاية  لأفعل الألم الذي
أشعر به أثناء التدرب ودفع
نفسي الذي يأتي معه ، لكن هذا
أحد الأشياء التي دفعتني حقًا إلى
النسيان ، لقد كان شيئًا لم أستطع
فعله بسهولة ، فأنا أحب التحدي الذي أجعله
تحت هذا الشريط تمامًا كل
الوقت يعني العالم المطلق الذي أشعر فيه
بالنسيان إلى حد كبير ، وفي كل مكان كنت أعمل فيه
في America's Got Talent
مرتين ، كنت في برنامج Ellen DeGeneres
Show ، لقد كنت في برنامج The Late Late Show
مع James Corden عندما أرى
ردود فعل الناس وكيف  إن
تقديري لقدرتي على القيام بهذا أمر مذهل ،
فأنا أحبهم تمامًا ، فأنا أحب
كل شيء عن ذلك ،
يعتقد الناس أن طي النسيان كان للمتعة فقط
للترينيداديين مثلي هو حقًا
جزء كبير من ثقافتنا أشعر
أن هذا هو المكان الذي أتولى فيه وظيفتي  لتظهر لك حقًا
أن هذا أكثر من مجرد نشاط صغير ممتع
[موسيقى]